I want to tell you about a
generalization of a problem that was
first popularized by Al Cohen of York
who was an anglo-saxon really smart dude
the problem is you have a farmer who
comes to your river and with him he has
a wolf a bundle of cabbages and a goat
and there's a boat that's there and it
carry it can carry him and one of his
charges obviously the farmer has to be
there because he has to be rowing and he
wants to bring everything to the other
shore safely so that means that he
cannot leave the cabbage with the goat
because the go to be eating the cabbage
and he cannot leave the wolf with the
goat because then the wolf would eat the
goat so how can he do it and so of
course we're assuming that the wolf
cannot ask for him which is a question I
get all the time when I'm speaking to
kids so the wolf cannot swim neither can
a goat or the cabbage so the only thing
you can do it first is to bring the goat
okay so then okay the firmer goes back
and he takes let's say the wolf but now
he cannot leave the wolf with the cat
that with the goat otherwise the wolf
would eat the goat back so what if he
brown the cabbage instead well same
thing if he brings the cabbage now the
goat would eat the cabbage so the only
way to scan be done yes you have to have
this clever moment of saying oh I can
bring back the goat so okay he brown the
cabbage over and now he brings back the
goat and now takes the wolf brings it to
the other side as well and now he goes
back just to get his goat so then you
can generalize you can say well let's
say that this farmer had more things
that he wanted to carry across the river
so let's say that I added a rabbit so
what can I do first what does a rabbit
day with what oh yeah good question
right so the wolf would eat the rabbit
and well the rabbit would eat the
cabbage we assume that the rabbit and a
goat together or fine there won't be too
much violence there the boat can hold
the farmer and one of these guys that's
it the farmer still has to be there
we're still assuming also that the revit
cannot swim so what can I bring first
can I bring the wolf well no obviously
the rabbit and a go to the eat the
cabbage
can I bring the rabbit wellnot again to
go to the eating the cabbage if the wolf
doesn't catch the gold first okay can I
bring the goat well no the rabbit will
eat the cabbage again if the wolf
doesn't catch the rabbit first and can I
bring the cabbage no because the wolf
would eat the rabbit in the goat carnage
carnage yes blood everywhere no matter
what we do or shreds of cabbage one or
the other so the question becomes okay
how big of a boat do I need so if I'm
given different things and I know
there's certain conflicts how big does
my boat have to be so here if I have
space for my farmer plus two other
things I'll be fine
I could just say fine I'll bring the
wolf and cabbage first I'll leave them
on the other side come back and get my
rabbit and goat super easy so the
question is how big does it have to be
well now we kind of want to start doing
math right so how do we bring math in
there so we want to think about the
conflicts as making a graph so I have my
wolf and I have my goat and so I cannot
leave my wolf with my goat so I'll put
an ad the line between these two points
which are really normally called
vertices yeah conflict that these two
things cannot be left alone unsupervised
the wolf can also not be left with the
rabbit the goat cannot be left with the
cabbage and the rabbit cannot be left
with the cabbage either but the wolf can
be left with a cabbage so I don't draw
an edge there and I don't draw an edge
between my goat in my rabbit because it
can be left together okay the point that
we see is that let's say that I first
took my rabbit well there's still some
lines remaining right I am left with a
graph with the wolf goat and cabbage and
there's still some lines that are
remaining and that's tree firing remove
any of the corners so what I want to do
is take a set of my things that will
remove all of the lines and that's
actually a really important math concept
it's called a vertex cover so maybe
let's write down what is the vertex
cover a vertex cover and a graph
is a set of vertices such that any edge
is adjacent to at least one of these
services okay
so what does that mean that means that
if I want to take a set of points where
every line is touching at least one of
these points my goal is that by taking
the vertex cover I'm removing all the
lines so maybe we can just draw a simple
example so let's say that I have this
graph so this is a graph so a graph is
really just a set of points and set of
lines called vertices and edges and so I
might ask myself what is a vertex cover
so I could start building one so I could
say okay I'll take this vertex within my
vertex cover but that's not enough right
so these five edges now are covered by
this vertex right they're touching this
vertex but the other ones aren't yet now
so I could ask I could add this vertex
to my vertex cover and so I'm getting
closer but I still have this line that
is not covered yet so I could add this
one now and so these three vertices from
a vertex cover every single line is
adjacent to one of these vertices it's
almost like how many hands did you need
to cover the right number of spots yeah
exactly exactly so here in a vertex
cover what was it well yeah one is not
sufficient right a single vertex is not
a vertex cover if I cover the rabbit and
the goat then they're covering all of
the edges there's no edges remaining so
this forms a vertex cover so that's why
I need to have at least two seats
because the minimum size of a vertex
cover in there is 2 so there's no way
that I can do it if I don't have at
least two extra places besides the place
for the form
so in general I know that my boat has to
have at least the minimum size of a
vertex cover right otherwise I won't be
able to make my first trip because there
will be some lines remaining in my graph
and lines represent conflict I imagine
you could do overkill though there must
be as these things get more complicated
there must be vertex covers that cover
too many vertices oh yeah that's a
really good point right so in this graph
for example
so if I add this vertex this is still a
vertex cover right so I really want the
minimum one so I want to say that the
number of extra places needed in my boat
is at least the size of the minimum
vertex cover so in this graph here that
was three I needed to have at least
three because that small yeah you don't
want to overkill as you said so that's
nice but now you might ask yourself will
that always be enough right
like sure you can do the first trip
across the river but will you be able to
do all of them and so now you could
check with some examples so I mean we
could try with a big example and see if
it works out and then try with some
other examples does that sound good okay
so maybe we need another piece of paper
okay so now we have way more things and
so now we need to think for a second
what is actually going to eat what and
we might disagree on some of these I am
NOT a farm girl so I would go with what
I think the wolf would eat the goose
potentially the mouse if it's really
hungry told eat grass it's one ain't a
cat either I don't think so carrot or
cabbage it's not a vegetarian it's a
carnivore so set a goat and the rabbit
and the goose will eat the grass I see
geese eating grass all the time I don't
think it's gonna eat carrot or cabbage
because it doesn't really have does it
have teeth does I don't think I mean
certainly if it's not cut up you know
like it will have trouble it doesn't
have hands - maybe this does not the
taste of cabbage fine
I think the mouse will eat carrot and
cabbage and the cat will eat the mouse
certainly the grass will probably be
eaten by the goat I know that you can
use them as long Moore's the rabbit
might eat some grass
cat I think it will just eat the mouse
and nothing else will eat it the rabbits
gonna
yes so the cabbage yeah that's true so
the rabbit will eat the carrot and the
goat will probably eat the carrot too
and the rabbit will also eat the cabbage
and so will the goat and then the goat
and a rabbit are fine I think that's
that looks reasonable to me do you agree
okay so let's say that I have a river
how big it boat we need and will the
minimum vertex cover be enough the first
point I really want to make is that
finding the minimum vertex cover is not
easy right so here we only have nine
things right it's not that much and to
figure out what it is well since this
graph has some meaning I'm going to use
the meaning to help me so I basically
have like my carnivores my herbivores
and then I have the poor vegetables and
herbs and so these three categories kind
of help me determine that oh maybe the
goat rabbit goose and mouse so my
herbivores might form a vertex cover and
I think if I look at it carefully like
if I were to really look at every single
line so actually yes the mouse the goose
the rabbit and a goat do form a vertex
cover it's unclear if that is actually
the smallest I claim it is it's not an
actually such an easy thing to check so
let's just assume that I'm right so what
I'll do is I'll say okay for my first
trip I will take my minimum vertex cover
right so if I remove my goat rabbit
boots and mouse and bring them to the
other side I am left I removed all of
the lines here and so okay that's fine
so then my farmer will come back we can
only take four things it will leave a
thing behind us say it leaves the cat
behind and so he brings these guys but
certainly the wolf will attack these
guys and these guys will eat all of the
vegetables and grass so I'll bring them
back so it's the same trick as we've
seen before I'll carry my cat over so
that it doesn't eat my mouse just itself
right it's just four places but you can
just bring one thing that's completely
fine
and then I will finally go back so
there's no conflict here all right this
was the original things that I had left
at first so no problem there and then
I'll bring my four leftover herbivores
and leave them there when I'm done
so I succeeded in this case right but
that's not a proof right maybe maybe I
wouldn't need more and certainly we've
just seen okay finding your minimum
vertex cover is not necessarily so easy
so maybe let's do one other example so
let's say that I had just my wolf and my
four herbivores that would get eaten by
my wolf if he has a chance
so my wolf would eat all of these and
none of these would attack each other
right so I have my river so I know that
I need to have at least the number of
extra places should be at least the size
of my minimum vertex cover which here is
easy to calculate what is it Brady do
you know it's one it's one I'm very
impressed
okay so my wolf is my minimum vertex
cover so I need to bring my well first
right that's the only thing I can do if
I bring anything else I'll be left with
some conflict so I bring my wolf over I
come back as I can only take one thing
so let's say that I take the mouse but
they all really look the same like the
graph all looks the same for all of them
and these are cold different things but
it could have been called you know go
two one go two go three go for really so
I bring my mouse over so now I have no
choice but to bring the wolf pack
right otherwise my wolf would eat my
mouse so I bring the wolf pack and then
well I'm kind of stuck right so either I
bring one of these guys but then my wolf
would eat the two remaining guys or I
bring the wolf again and I keep going
like this and I'm stuck it doesn't work
it doesn't work so how much do you need
how much bigger does it have to be and
the amazing thing is you just need one
more at whatever the graph
of conflicts is you will only need at
most one more than your minimum vertex
cover and so the way to do it is very
simple you have these conflictual things
that you know like like your wolf here
so you just put all these conflictual
individual individuals in the boat with
you at all times so you can watch them
and then one by one you carry everything
else so here okay
yeah the wolf is with you the whole time
it does every trip back and forth so now
let's say that I have the minimum vertex
cover plus 1 seats extra so I have 2
seats plus a farmer's seat so I'll take
my wolf in my mouth first
I'll leave the mouse there bring back my
wolf take now my goose with my wall
leave my goose come back with in my wolf
take my goat in my wolf but my go there
come back with my wolf and then carry
finally the last 8 and this will work no
matter how big your vertex cover is
right so no matter how big it is you
just keep it with you in your boat and
then one by one you carry everything
else that's pretty amazing so you know
that you need at least a minimum vertex
cover and you need at most the minimum
vertex cover plus one to be able to do
it and the amazing thing is that
distinguishing between both knowing one
you need one and not the other is
actually really hard
it's np-hard so this is a recent result
by three mathematicians Shaba Virginia
Hannah Harkins and yes it's an amazing
thing this small difference of one is
hard to determine
so sometimes minimum vertex cover will
do the trick
yeah just like in the previous example
yeah sometimes you need to go plus one
and to know which is which
just by looking into graph is hard so
for certain classes of graphs we do know
it but for a general graph we don't and
it's very hard hard problem actually if
you couldn't solve it you'll be a
millionaire so you know something to try
at home
so this is the alkene number of the
graph but so it relates because it's
np-hard
to determine whether you need a minimum
vertex
cover our the minimum vertex cover plus
one if you were able to come up with a
polynomial time algorithm to determine
for any graph what it is then you would
prove that P is equal to NP so big
problems this video was brought to you
by the mathematical sciences Research
Institute one of the top places for
mathematics in all the world and
whatever you think about the mathematics
they do there they must have the best of
you of any maths Institute in the world
San Francisco Bay Berkeley unbelievable
if you'd like to find out more about
MSRI I'll put some links in the
description under the video it's worth a
look